President Trump telling Seattle leaders
to shut down the police free zone or he
will the president calling out
Democratic politicians after hundreds of
protesters took over a section of the
city and after police abandoned a
precinct we're not gonna let Seattle be
occupied by anarchists and I'm not
calling tippy-toe jesters I'm not cause
they know I but I got to see a
performance that I've never seen I mean
you think he was a weak person and
Minneapolis the woman I don't know has
she ever done this before if there were
more toughness you wouldn't have the
kind of devastation that you had in
Minneapolis and in Seattle I mean let's
see what's going on and I will tell you
if they don't straighten that situation
out we're gonna straighten it out those
comments coming amid reports of armed
guards and possible extortion and the so
called autonomous zone the protesters
making a list of demands including
defunding the police D gentrification
and free College Seattle's mayor is
pushing back against criticism and just
downplaying the matter entirely watch
lawfully gathering and expressing First
Amendment rights demanding we do better
as a society and providing true equity
for communities of color is not
terrorism it is patriotism we've got
four blocks in Seattle that you just saw
pictures of that is more like a block
party atmosphere it's not an armed
takeover we have block parties and the
like and this part of Seattle all the
time it's it's known for that how long
do you think Seattle and those few
blocks looks like this I don't know we
could have a Summer of Love
I gotta go to you Kenny you know this
part of the world pretty well what do
you think's going on get your thoughts
Kennedy yeah I grew up in Portland I
lived in Seattle
I love the weirdo atmosphere but this
has gone so far beyond that because what
you're seeing is really a totalitarian
takeover of people who want a one-party
state there's no longer freedom of
expression or free exchange of ideas and
it's interesting because you talk about
D gentrification what does that mean how
do you write something like that down if
you're if you're passing something
through the City Council you know how
does local government mandate something
like D gentrification and that's the
problem with these broad terms is they
ultimately have fascist outcomes and it
actually reminds me of Greg's
I believe second book not cool oh well
if people are beholding to the mob and
they no longer think for themselves it's
no longer about individual rights
freedom of expression or anything like
that you're really just doing everything
to appease a group of people to whom you
want to appear cool and that's what
Seattle's mayor reminds me of Greg you
are not necessarily a reader of crystal
balls but you did see this coming and
not cool is one of the but commentary on
this show for a while and now all of a
sudden this theory of what could happen
if they actually got their way is now
happening in Seattle well I might blow
my horn now since both of you had led
the way a joy of hate predicted cancel
culture not cool protected this kind of
revolutionary change you can't make
demands when you're seceding right I
don't understand that this is not a
divorce you are leaving the country so
the demands are off the table okay so
here I'm gonna be fair the bad thing
about this is they're doing it on other
people's property that's wrong the good
thing is they're experimenting they're
putting their money which they have none
where their mouth is so if they actually
do okay maybe they can get some land and
leave us alone and again I respect them
more than the people like John Legend
who are pushing for defunding the police
from their gated mansions at least these
freaks are going out and given it a shot
but the thing that is lost on the left
and Kennedy mentions it places where
there is little law and order it's not
freedom it's actually the least free you
can find if you go to Sudan it's ruled
by criminals and warlords because they
have no security by the way just
Update I have been checking with human
resources about being fox news's warlord
I'm waiting to see the help I'm waiting
to see the health benefits because it's
hard when you're pillaging and the 401k
package which I'm investing in hemp and
tattoo ink okay well well you keep keep
us informed John Lord negotiations yes
one I'm curious about the idea of some
of these things that they come up with
like a demand for free college this is a
now this is just everybody's demand
everybody's demand and the somebody like
a Joe Biden has already said okay well
we'll go ahead in that direction I don't
understand how the whole free college
thing works in this scenario what why
would the mayor be able to give that to
them I don't think the mayor can give
that to them Dana I think this is an
expression of young people who are
frustrated the high cost of higher
education in this country but look this
is all to me just a political play and
it's morally selective outrage by a
president who wants to paint these young
people as anarchists and terrorists and
they're terrible people and in fact
they're young people as the mayor said
who are engaged in things like poetry
readings free speech art in an art
district in Seattle and the mayor says
it's lawful she is supporting it as you
just heard
but Trump wants to turn them into bad
guy so you know why because then he can
play Dirty Harry he can dominate them
right these are a bunch of kids but he
needs something at this moment here by
the way I didn't hear the right wing
echo chamber go off in 2016 when you had
actual armed men take over federal
property in Oregon and threatened people
and interfere with federal workers know
then there was like crickets so I think
there's a lot of hypocrisy here because
I think front knows he's not doing well
in handling these protests but you also
play down what was going on - Juan
whenever there was like oh that's
largely a protest is that the two bad
apples
so let's the hip-hop
Corsi could be spread evenly right no
wait a second wait a second I do think
this had been overwhelmingly peaceful
legitimate protest about there you go
rages situation that's my point
Jessie did you know that this idea for
an autonomous zone apparently they're
gonna try it in Nashville Oh tonight the
governor saying that's not happening but
the mayor mr. Cooper I don't know what
he said so far but he's been out there
with protesters but he won't let
somebody like John Rich's little kid
play in the Little League games this
weekend like everything's a mess it's no
it's not it's not just this little
six-block area it could actually spread
yeah I don't see John Rich tolerating an
autonomous zone in Nashville no I don't
think it's gonna go over too well with
the people of Tennessee but can we back
up for a second if Greg is a warlord at
Fox that is the softest coup we've ever
witnessed in world history and also why
is everybody kissing gut fields but so
badly like I'm about to throw up over
here I mean the guys Ito is as big as as
trumps at this point does he need more
stroking he does not and also to Juan's
point one I've never seen a peaceful
protest injure 700 NYPD officers and and
cost hundreds of millions of dollars in
property damage okay so let's get that
straight and as someone who does not
consider themselves that mature when
Jesse Watters feels more mature than
elected mayors and governors of states
we have a real problem on our hands you
wouldn't let your children like lock
themselves in a room in your house and
start making demands of their parents
right no you'd kick the door down and
they'd be grounded for the rest of the
summer I mean this is not Sleepless in
Seattle
this is spineless in Seattle this might
be probably the worst thing that come
out of Seattle since grunge I don't say
this like hey when you walk back back
Jesse Watters
no no you do not have the right to
lecture the world about CFCs
particularly grunge and anything in the
90s but what I will say is this movement
allows the City Council immediately not
pay attention to the homeless crisis
homelessness in a wealthy city like
Seattle has gotten out of control and
now they don't have to address that
because they can talk about the Summer
of Love you know and I guess
homelessness is just camping
never mind the the women and the
vulnerable who were sexually assaulted
in situations like that this according
to the Seattle chief of police talking
about Chaz